The values for these fields are 0.209,
which is a total positive correlation.
So that means that as the total
day in minutes goes up, so
does the amount of true values.
What I also notice is the p-values
are less than 0.05 which
as we learned in Patrick's lesson means
they are statistically significant.
This stars to the right are an indicator
of the significance and simply,
the more stars means the more
significant they are.
This chart that we're able to get from
Altrex does a good job at showing
what variables we should consider for
using in our model.
With this list we now
need to go into examining
intercorrealation within
our predictor variables.